foreign
Alex is with us in Louisville Kentucky
hi Alex welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys how's it going great what's up
so I got a a 20 000 debt that is being
garnished weekly from my my paycheck
ouch what's that from
it's from a side by side that I
purchased and then lost
wow okay
expensive side by side
yes yeah I've got all the bells and
whistles
and I'm curious I have about eighty
thousand dollars in equity in my home
and another six thousand dollars in
personal loan and credit card debt if I
should sell my house and pay off all my
debts and just rent until I can buy
again
or how much other debt other than the 20
say it again
it's 26 000 total in debt but 20 of it
is this garnishment
yes
what's your car worth
uh about five thousand are you married
no divorced
how much do you make a year
68 000.
and you have no money I assume no you
would have already paid it you wouldn't
have called us right right yeah
okay
okay is that just from one one job or do
or by chance do other things okay this
is one job
well that's good news
how much is your house payment
uh my house payment's right at a
thousand one hundred okay
you have kids
yes four
okay
do you have custody of the kids
uh 50 50.
okay
um well the house is always the last
thing I sell
and then I the the question I always ask
myself and then all of us here on the
show ask ourselves is what would we do
if we woke up in your shoes
what would be our next step
um so if I'm a
divorcee a bachelor the house is not
that big a deal I do need a decent place
that I'm renting that I can take the
four kids to right when it's my turn to
keep it but um but home ownership uh
just uh a bachelor you know loading up
your stuff and moving out it's not that
big a deal emotionally how long ago was
the divorce
about six months ago yeah okay
um
if I'm in your shoes a fresh start does
sound pretty appealing
so yeah cleaning this thing off and uh
and then you know storing the rest of
that and restart my baby steps you're
debt free now you build your emergency
fund then you start saving to buy a
house because my guess is if you had 80
000 in the middle of the kitchen table
you wouldn't go buy a house right now
obviously you would pay these things off
you'd set your emergency phone in place
and you start working towards the house
um is there anything in particular about
this house that causes you want just
dying to keep it
well actually the house is almost
getting too small for the number of kids
it has
[Music]
okay well I'm kind of thinking if I if
I'm in your shoes twenty six thousand
dollars when you make sixty eight
thousand dollars isn't that much money
we have people pay off a lot more than
that and not very long and you have 50
50 custodies so you you said that 68 000
is from one job and so you have margin
with your time when when the kids are
with their mom if I'm in your shoes I'm
going gazelle intense and just knocking
off that twenty six thousand dollars now
that's not to say you don't sell the
house just because you want to sell the
house but I think you can knock this out
yeah you could probably be done in uh
nine ten months
I mean 2 600 bucks a month
but that's just living on beans and rice
rice and beans and working two jobs you
know and you know just rolling up your
sleeves and saying I want this crap out
of my life I want all this negative
things in my rear view mirror now that
the divorce is in my rear view mirror
rather than looking at and then I've got
a clean future out ahead up man I'm a
homeowner with a bunch of equity so
um
yeah I I
I think it's an awesome opportunity to
just clean it up if you go do what
Christina said that's a probably a
better plan than I was coming up with
I'm just trying to think it's probably
emotionally wrung out after the divorce
and but you don't have the you know the
constructions on your time so you got
the kids when you got the kids but when
you don't be at work right well they can
hear so much heaviness in his voice and
it's easy when you're in those really
heavy situations to only tunnel in in on
big switch sweeping actions so paying
off the house selling the house having
that eighty thousand dollars that feels
good because it's an immediate win but I
think you can fight through this and I
think that you need to hear that you can
do this I think I mean we see people on
these debt-free stages on the step-free
stage all the time who've paid off way
more money than that and have a really
difficult situation so I think right now
I just want to encourage you that you
can do this you can have a house with 80
000 in equity and have no debt if you're
willing to fight for it yeah one of the
things we always say around here we got
something tough in front of us
business-wise as we say what must be
true
so ask yourself what must be true for me
to have three thousand dollars a month
on this debt and be done in nine months
what must be true that means I'm working
two jobs three jobs and I'm living never
seeing inside of a restaurant and we're
not buying a bunch of crap and we're not
going on vacation and we're going to
clean up the mess and the mess that we
made with the side by side freaking
Bentley side by side but um that you end
up twenty thousand bucks upside down on
it I mean that's a story how do you I
mean I can imagine buying one for twenty
thousand but how do you end up losing
twenty thousand on one but I think he
already feels that shame like I can hear
that no I'm just saying that that's the
thing I want all that if I'm him I want
all that in my rearview mirror right and
so you can channel that if I'm him to be
angry not at myself but just at cleaning
up the mess exactly and how good is it
going to feel to know that you fought
through it that you took ownership of it
and that you fought to pay off that debt
when you get to the other side of that
you're going to have such a feeling of
just relief and pride in the fact that
yeah you made a mistake but you know
what you fought to overcome that mistake